في هذه الأثناء أم الدمار في غزة
مستمر أه بينما يستهدف الجيش الإسرائيلي حماس أه الأمم المتحدة
تقول أن إحدى مدارسها في
شمال غزة قصفت أمس
المدرسة كانت تستخدم كملجأ
يقولون إن الفيديو من مكان الحادث يبدو أنه
يظهر عشرات الجثث بما في ذلك
جثث النساء والأطفال أم ماذا
تعرف عن هذه الضربة هل
تعتقد الإدارة أن هذا نتيجة
الضربة الإسرائيلية لذلك أه ما زلنا نجمع
معلومات حول هذه الحادثة التي
حدثت للتو أه بالأمس كنا على
اتصال مباشر مع أونرا أه  وكالة الأمم المتحدة
على الأرض أه في غزة والتي
بالمناسبة أه فقدت أكثر من 100
فرد من موظفيها أه تعرف
الناس الذين يتجولون يوزعون
أه المساعدات داخل غزة التقيت أه
افتراضيا مع رئيس أونرا فقط
قبل يومين أه ما يمكنني قوله
في هذه المرحلة ونحن أيضًا على اتصال
مع الإسرائيليين لمحاولة معرفة ما
يعرفونه عما حدث هو
أنه إذا أه وقع أذى أه على أه
المدنيين الأبرياء أه يحتمون في
موقع الأمم المتحدة سيكون غير مقبول على الإطلاق
أه ولذلك سنستمر في
محاولة النظر في ما حدث في هذه
اللحظة عندما نعرف المزيد سنشاركه
الرئيس بايدن عندما سافر إلى
إسرائيل بعد هجوم حماس يوم
7 أكتوبر وقتل حوالي 1  ،00 الإسرائيليين
الرئيس بايدن حذر إسرائيل من
ارتكاب نفس الأخطاء التي ارتكبتها أمريكا
بعد 11/9 ألا تسمح أه الغضب أه أن
يستهلكهم لا تسمح للغضب أن يوجه
ردهم أنت أكثر من الذين
أه يشاهدون العرض الآن و  أكثر
مني يعرف مدى
استهداف الجيش الإسرائيلي لحماس فعليًا، وما
إذا كان الإسرائيليون يبذلون
كل ما في وسعهم لتجنب وقوع
إصابات في صفوف المدنيين، وما مدى سوء
عدد القتلى المدنيين في الواقع مقابل
ما تدعي وزارة الصحة الفلسطينية التي تديرها حماس،
ومدى انتشار
الدمار.  في الواقع، في غزة، هل
تعتقد أن الإسرائيليين أخذوا بنصيحة بايدن
بشأن عدم السماح للانتقام بأن يكون مدفوعًا
بالغضب؟ ما يمكنني قوله حول هذا هو أنه
ليس تقييمًا يمكن
إجراؤه بناءً على لقطة في
لحظة معينة، هذا تقييم مستمر  محادثة
أه بين الولايات المتحدة
وحكومة إسرائيل وعندما تكون هناك
حوادث مثل تلك
التي ذكرتها للتو أه تثير
المخاوف أه توحي أه ربما
أنه لم يتم الاهتمام بما فيه الكفاية
أه بأرواح الفلسطينيين
الأبرياء أه  التي تعلمونها
تساوي أرواح الأبرياء أه على أي حال
هذا يجب أن يذهب دون أن نقول أننا نثير
هذه المخاوف مباشرة مع
حكومة إسرائيل وقد
أثار الرئيس تلك المخاوف مباشرة أه مع
رئيس الوزراء لذلك أه بالنسبة لنا الأمر
أقل من حقيقي  -تقييم الوقت وأكثر من ذلك بكثير
عن عملية مستمرة
لمحاولة توجيه الأمور بأفضل ما يمكن
أه الاتجاه بما في ذلك أه لما
تبقى من القتال أه خلال
هذا الصراع نعتقد أه
يمكن لحكومة إسرائيل أن
تستخلص منها الدروس أه على أساس  كيف
سارت العمليات في الشمال أه أه
وتطبيق تلك الدروس أه أينما
ذهب الصراع أه للأمام